I want to get into the the problem
solving like what would you do if you
were the daily wire okay so the only
thing and this is the thing this is all
done right now I don't I'm not saying
that I have all the answers but the
first answer and I've said we won't talk
about this again if someone takes a
pledge alongside me anyone in VidCon
just the only thing that I ask is that
you do not punish conservative content
creators on behalf of big Tech that's it
start with that let's start with that
before we get to everything else right A
lot of times people want the entire
solution just start with that you won't
be penalized 25 if you're demonetized on
YouTube by the people who are supposed
to be fighting for you